at the core of disruption are heightened
customer expectations they want instant
great experiences iBM has developed the
IBM cloud garage method to guide clients
on transforming how they go from an idea
to design to development to deployment
of applications you focus on who the end
user is what that user needs and desires
and what needs to be built and validated
to meet those needs
companies arrive and deliver their
minimal viable products to test out
their concepts and refine them
their adoption of the IBM cloud platform
and the garag method
American Airlines delivered in a few
months what used to take them a year or
more their application allows you to
dynamically rebook flights when you're
delayed getting you on flights much
faster lowering cost and increasing
customer satisfaction the outcomes for
every garage engagement are applications
that engage end-users in compelling new
ways the IBM cloud platform is built for
the garage method with tools that
reflect the process every step along the
way
you